everyone gather gather around in a line
okay i had to get my fit
right i gotta be orange zach move up
push over a little bit
make some room oh don't get in front of
me come on what are you doing zach
ian you're too far get in line we gotta
all be like here
perfect line come on now guys like
avengers uh
on the yellow line avengers how's
everyone moving
i'm on the yellow line if i go on the
yellow line i'm behind the box
i okay i'm just gonna do an intro now
okay
today we gather around my friends to
play
the first ever round of among us h3
podcast edition and i will say
good luck to everybody i watched several
tutorials
tutorials on how on the best possible
careers
the best possible imposter strategies
and i have a 2
trillion iq so best of luck to everybody
i'm suspicious of eli she's
standing here which makes me think it's
her
i think it's him
it's gotta be
it literally has to be oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] damn it damn god damn it dan i knew
i knew his dan as uh trisha would say
[ __ ] you dan
[Music]
scared me
oh wow okay hey
i have i have some thoughts here yeah
i'll throw you a curveball i mean i was
the one that had found it the only
person i saw in that area was zack
i ran into him right before it was over
in the reactor room we just ran into
each other and then there was a body
i saw you dip down man i don't know
you're pretty sus
it's zack you guys are so wrong
enjoy the voice you're so wrong you're
so wrong
here comes that big v oh wait what
we called an emergency meeting because
we know it's dan
for zach yeah all right zach we don't
you all die eventually enjoy space idiot
[Laughter]
i'm sorry zack he was a he was a good
one but man
he's just a bad truth teller apparently
i don't know he's bad at telling the
truth
so if you win as imposter you get 100
bucks love it
sounds good i gotta sabotage this game
real quick because i have to pee again
oh my god
standoff dan is trying to totally kill
ila right now
or eli's trying to kill me
i saw ela in the right standing on top
of a vent
i don't know how she got over there did
you did anybody
pass ela on the way i i did i did
however i have to say ethan was stalking
me
i'm if i'm being a weirdo it's because
i'm still trying to understand what i'm
doing
well i was waiting to jump in because we
can't talk over each other but i think
it's down
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it's ila but i can't talk but it's
either it was between dan or ela if it
wasn't dan then it's ila
but we don't have any actual evidence
that you know
i think it was down there and one of
them was trying to kill me but they've
seen the other
i gotta go a b on this one sorry dude
god it's it's probably ela isn't it
i trust zach i think zack's innocent i
want
zach and i to go do tasks and ethan and
ela to go do tasks
oh interesting we're all still alive
okay it's zach but you saw me either i
was walked off i wasn't in the huddle oh
my
god this is some co-conspiracy [ __ ]
hold on hold on zach defend yourself
zach
i saw ela kill ian it was right in the
daylight
it was in [ __ ] daylight that's
[ __ ]
you're so suspicious elo why was it not
you and why was it zack
because if it was me i would do it in a
better situation
okay oh my god
this is some co-conspiracy [ __ ] man
enjoy space idiot
god i'm pregnant you [ __ ] up man i'm
praying i'm right
you know i was i was uh i was leaning
ela but then i was like i should i
should support my wife
oh i told you that's some co-conspiracy
man i was gonna follow ethan
he got me kicked last time i'm gonna
mess with him unless he's the killer
that would
[Laughter]
i knew it was gonna be him i'm like why
that's my luck
this is a little unfortunate timing but
i was on security cams
and i saw ethan kill ab
i it was me and abe and ian in that
whole thing
i didn't see a body i was literally just
doing tasks
and ian is accusing me of killing a b
enjoy space
it's ian good job guys it's ian bye i'm
voting ian off so
whatever it is oh my god first no matter
what happened
no matter what
[Music]
all right just remember it's ian oh i
can't talk anymore sorry
oh [ __ ] i'm dead no
okay so not dan unless it is dan and
he's just using some
next level strategy
oh
zacky boy wow already
so what's this someone kill zach
who was it ethan was the only one still
over there
right unless elisa
oh my god this is happening again it was
definitely ela that killed zach
okay i can vouch for i can vouch for a b
i saw a b
uh doing a task right before this
happens
i was i was in the same area with it was
ian
ila and zach and we were all in that
same area and i went down to do a task
and then either reported a dead body
eli what do you have to say sounds like
it's you ethan
that's a little suspicious just by your
own logic it sounds like it's you then
what how because you said there was
three people including yourself
so it sounds like it's you if ela killed
him and then reported the body
i'm gonna vote eli this time but if it's
not then it's almost guaranteed ethan
i'm giving it to ethan
thanks he ian at least someone believes
in me
well enjoy being enjoy being killed by
eli everybody
bye
enjoy space ethan
break my heart man i don't have any
patience i just want to kill people
[Laughter]
i'm just gonna do my own thing i'm gonna
hide from everyone
i feel like i keep getting killed either
first or second
okay ethan totally just busted him
it was dan i saw him do it it was ethan
no no no i'm literally telling you i
walked in on dan killing abe
that's it i walked in okay he killed him
fair enough
so then called it on himself dan what do
you have to do
okay i'll tell you what happened i was
trying i was on top of the body trying
to call it and i don't know
i don't know why it wasn't triggering it
but dan was trying to kill me
and he was on top of the body as well i
don't know what
what that just got confusing yeah what
wait that's what dan called it where was
the body
i walked in from the electrical room i'm
trying not to
please let me finish i walked in on the
electrical room you're a murderer dan
let me finish
shame on you and he was in there with
abe's corpse
wait don't vote no slow down well it's
dan he's voting for me he's giving
himself away okay let's fly bam talk
can i have my turn and anyway i was on
top of them
trying to call a meeting let me finish i
was on top of the body trying to call a
meeting before dan killed me
and he was trying to kill me how do you
call a meeting when you see a dead body
does it automatically
right no you walk up to the body
and you declare and you call a meeting
which i did
after i saw you kill a b okay
so i was on top of the body trying to
call a meeting because i don't know how
it works and dan
saw it we're standing over the body it
was ethan
it was ethan hey wait i dan did you
did you actually see ethan kill or did
you just walk up and he was standing no
he was standing over the body i saw him
kill i literally saw it happen
and it was by the electrical room i
don't know exactly the right way
yeah because i had a task in there it's
ethan
what kind of task then it's a thousand
percent ethan it's like fix
the wiring or something it's fine if i'm
dead then
and it's not me you'll know it's stan
it's ethan well not
i mean i didn't see anything i'm telling
you guys i didn't see him kill
a beast
now i'm just telling you i'm trying to
protect my hundred it's dan it was right
next to an event too
okay bye it's definitely dan just
remember and he's trying to cover his
tracks
you guys are idiots bye
oh okay i'm not going anywhere
you can we can still do tasks
what happens when the oxygen runs out
ah it's game over we lose see ya idiots
[Applause]
you got an oxygen wind that seems kind
of shady dan
yeah it's [ __ ] i don't even know
what i was supposed to do
i'll give him a hundred bucks no i'd
take you
hey no should i give him 10 bucks
you juicing man that's a barry bonds win
man
okay oh [ __ ] you leave me alone
leave me alone she's blocking that [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] ela's going to kill me
too many people were safe
[Music]
[Applause]
stay away from me yeah yeah dan give my
back give my back
yeah oh what you listen look what elo
dude you look suspect
dan dan i'm staying with you dan
he was trying to hunt my ass down right
now
[Music]
zach's been here forever
what i would like to report is zach has
just been sitting at the cameras
for like the entire game which i find
extremely suspicious
and i think everybody's seen that okay
yeah i agree with his deck thing also i
feel like ilo has been chasing me down
for like five minutes
she has been i've seen it
no i was because when you've seen dan
you backed off a little bit
no you can't
hold on hold on there's not enough
evidence chasing down thing
abe was chasing me hardcore and i was
running for my [ __ ] life
until i got to ela and then he walked
into the room
saw that there were two people and like
hesitated and then walked away
okay it totally damned then because one
of them
one of them one of them backed off i was
trying to follow you to stay safe
because i thought hilo is hunting me
down
abs throwing a little guilt on dan kind
of quickly
yep i it's very a b fashion i think it's
a b
it was amazing you are acting sounds as
[ __ ]
up i'm a lurker zach why the why are you
sitting at the console the entire game
do you not care about how i've created
i've never
been the imposter you don't think like
the first thing i would do is kill
someone
i'm so excited to do that i've never
been the imposter
so what do you what do you will just
want to hope to see something on the
camera
what are you bird watching over there
i'm skipping it all right
as well but i got my eyes on you
[ __ ]
wow what happened i just found zach
uh i honestly didn't see any because i
was just
i finished all my tasks so i've been
running around in circles to just avoid
getting killed
i found him in the bottom right of the
map just now
uh i hadn't been to the bottom right in
a while the last person i saw was ela
but she was coming from the same
direction as me so i
don't think it's her the question is is
dan trying to do this whole bit
where he's like i reported the body in
the last game and won
so i wonder if that's gonna work for me
again it's a reverse psychologically i
understand why
no but i was just walking in the same
direction with them
from the cafeteria towards bottom right
because
she couldn't use this that body was
there for a while
well i'm telling you ab has been acting
us all game in my opinion but okay they
they know that we're on titan
no maybe it wasn't a b i'm sure i was
there
what is he he's trying to cast doubt on
a b like bro he was with me i got to say
dan
i can't tell i don't i'm telling you ila
tried to corner me in one of those rooms
she was trying to kill me making a
mistake
if it's not hello then well yeah for
sure ian what do you think
well i'll just vote with you guys now
but i am very suspicious of
what i was with her that's what i'm
saying why would i give her an alibi
bro dan he's trying to cover himself for
the next round get out of schedule all
right
good luck good luck to you all good luck
enjoy
enjoy the vacuum of space
oh wait hey wait what
what people voted for a b i literally
said he was with us
okay yeah back up okay hold on hold on
ian go ahead you called the meeting eli
do you have any tasks left
yes and a b do you have any yes i have
some left yes
okay your task is to kill everybody i
know and you haven't done that yet
absolutely listen
dan i'm a little skeptical with stan i
don't know
i just want to both ela and a b both say
they have tasks left
i wanna go see them do a task the bar
will fill up
and then sherlock [ __ ] homes over
here if both baby and ela's bars fill up
then it's definitely damn this is also
the reason why i don't think it's dan
because dan is slick with the sabotage
and there's been no sabotage this entire
game yeah dan
is trying to know that once we get rid
of elo we're going to look at him he's
he's setting up something
maybe it's ela i feel like ela's not
sabotaging
it could yeah it's not sabotaging i'll
say it
i've just suspicious because he was
acting sus but that doesn't
mean anything all right i want to go see
ila dutes first
okay ela we're all following ela
you hear that ela
what is this wild goose chase it's a
thousand percent elo
yeah i'm voting
really yep she's laughing like she knows
her goose is cooked
enjoy the vacuum of space
if she's not the imposter i'm going to
[ __ ] myself
yeah boy thank you for avenging my
nerves
zack young zachary you're looking
suspect
hmm interesting what's up
all right the body was in uh security
where the cameras are
okay zach just joined me and abn i know
zach loves hanging by the cameras
yeah and also in proximity to the
security room
it is close enough that he would have
made it no i was i was following
ela the whole time wait what i've been
with eli the whole game
has been following me the whole time
why would you call someone out that
wasn't with you
wait why would you say you're with ela
she she denies it
i'm giving you my alibi dude
i'm pleading the fifth here i want my
attorney i'm playing the fifth here
enjoy space [ __ ] you [ __ ] up
when you said you've been following ela
because i don't think we could have
proved it was you otherwise
had an alibi man i want my attorney it
was like two minutes earlier i was
i was a ghost for a while before anybody
i know it's gotta be corroboratable
i was in the vents at the time
okay who's going to be my friend
i'm going to take a risk and prove my
loyalty to ila
no she didn't kill me no
no oxygen i'm gonna let him die start a
new round
r.i.p guys you're getting good you did a
good team
[ __ ] nobody wants another one
what i don't get it
[Laughter]
why is it so easy to do nobody went to
because nobody went to the other one we
all went to the same one and it was ela
i [ __ ] knew it immediately
can i say something ela it's time to go
home gamer girl
wow that was fast really fast
where was the body it said cafeteria
right on the thing
i didn't see wait you reported it
okay maybe
kind of blew that one didn't you maybe
what do you mean you didn't see it you
reported it i did not hit her it's
[ __ ]
[Music]
i'm voting for amy
what why would you say it wasn't you
that was the most epic loss in in
imposter history
hope you guys all enjoyed watching that
i'm 200
poorer which is very sad and um
but we had some really good wholesome
fun and i hope you guys enjoyed it if
you do we'll just we'll play more we'll
just turn this into a straight up let's
play channel
you know [ __ ] the podcast let's just
play video games there's rules
i wish this was my job so anyway guys
this is
this is basically uh we're just trying
everything you know
seeing what you guys like so if you like
it let us know we'll do more
maybe you have some other games you want
to see us play we'll do that too
me and either taking friday off because
it's our anniversary and
also we're trying to get pregnant so
we're going to have a bunch of sex
nice uh happy anniversary guys i wasn't
expecting that much detail but
yeah thanks for the happy anniversary
and uh
that's what we'll be doing this weekend
so that's fun i'm actually excited
just to take the friday off and just to
be [ __ ] um
pound town talk to me baby it's not
really pop down in my case it's more
like
smash mountain smash
no i'm more like i'm more like the
teacup ride or some [ __ ]
just spin around get dizzy throw up i'm
like the pirate ship
ride it just goes back and forth really
slow
that's nice that's nice that's right
okay all right guys
[Music]
we shall see you next week so thank you
all for watching
let me know that i'm the winner oh oh
it's known it's known by all
go home gamer girl we don't want you
anymore
all right guys see you next time
you